with a little bit of fan fiction
imagining what a new series of Stargate
would look like and we came up with the
SGC I've already talked about two
seasons I'd like to do but I kind of
forgot to talk about the first series a
bit more so here we go welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular site tracker
you'll know that we've come up with this
idea it was actually Harris's idea
friend of the channel the young American
and we're doing a bit of a fan fiction
series called the SGC the idea being
that the series would be based in and
around Stargate command but then it
could Branch off into lots of other
directions we've already thought about
season two which would wander off and we
would get to see Atlantis again we've
already thought about season three where
we'd go and save Eli from the destiny
and revisit the SGU
but I might have forgotten a little bit
to talk more about the opening Series
and I'm gonna steal very heavily from a
script that I got told about that was
actually in development possibly written
by Dean Devlin a couple of years ago
that Amazon have decided to shred so the
Stargate command opening season really
does have to set up this new franchise
this new franchise idea that is going to
be a bit different to what we've seen
previously with Stargate but more in
line with sort of more modern streaming
shows I envisage Seasons that are 10
episodes that as I say Circle in and
around the SGC but that go off in lots
of different directions so a little bit
like Star Wars at the moment where we
see Mandalorian then Boba Fett but the
characters Mandalorian or in public and
so on and so on this idea is basically
an evolution of that in that we just get
more of an MCU style feel of a larger
universe and that each season will drop
in and out of different aspects of that
so how do we set this series up well I
actually have this idea and this opener
sequence based on a script that got
banded around a little while ago whereas
we see the Stargate in a big open space
it looks more like an airport or
something the Stargate sort of activates
and lights up but doesn't really open
properly and then we just see a person
appear the person initially is sort of
like like a ghost like grain you can't
really focus on him like he's blurry but
then as he steps forwards he sort of
crisps that and he becomes
human looking creature we then flip to
Daniel Jackson who is now the civilian
leader of the SGC but he started hearing
voices in his head he hears a voice of
maybe Omar or somebody else and the
voice is just saying don't trust him
don't trust him don't forget that if you
enjoy the content you can hit the join
button and become a fully fledged side
tracker that really helps out the
channel you can go to cygashtrack.com
there's loads of like merchandise things
on there and a load of new designs
coming very soon also if you are new to
the channel don't forget to like
subscribe and hit the Bell notification
so you miss none of our new videos as
well as the Sidetrack sides Channel
we then cut to a new opening sequence
and we get to see the you know Stargate
and all the characters and everything
else
in my show idea though then Daniel goes
to meet this person he's in a hold
himself you know they're interviewing
him and he says that he is a furling now
that immediately they think brilliant
feelings pacifists we love these guys
and we've never got to see them before
so we get to learn more about them
got the voice in Daniel Jackson's head
is still saying don't trust him don't
trust him now conversations then in this
first part of this series between Daniel
and the furling will allow us to tell
all the story about how we've got from
the end of the SGU to today how the
Stargate is now no longer a secret and
how people are traveling amongst the
Stars I want to think about us building
colonies within other parts of the
Galaxy and us actually trying to
bring the people of the Galaxy that was
spread out by the gold back together
again how perhaps we've created
alliances with the Jefferson but that's
very shaky ground I think the Jefferson
and the Lucian Alliance would probably
be in Conflict how we maybe have an
alliance with the remaining Tolland
um how we've constructing a fleet of BC
304s BC 305s and maybe even about to
launch a BC 306 but that's for a later
episode The furling doesn't know where
the Asgard are and he's asking about the
knocks and Daniel doesn't know why so he
is sparing on the information but the
feeling seems to know an awful lot about
their technology and keeps asking
questions about their position in the
Galaxy today now over a couple of
episodes I'd like to see a couple of
different teams coming in out I'd like
to see us going through the gate I think
I want to explore as I say where the
universe is now so I think we we would
be building quite large colonies on
other planets we have planets where
there are large numbers of people and
some of those have very little
technology so I could see us building
schools and hospitals and all this sort
of thing but also just the early shoots
of an actual large-scale interplanetary
Alliance start to form between Humanity
with Earth at its Center
I think we would I would love to see the
BC 304s bc305s that we talked about and
just get a feel of where Stargate is
today but
that is where the risk of this series
comes and we've talked about this lots
of times on the channel that it's got to
stay grounded though it's got to stay
within the Realms of what would make
sense we're only talking about maybe 12
years further down the line from what we
got to see at the start of Stargate
Universe so we've got to be careful we
don't go too far but the main element of
this series as I say is about this
furling character and his conversations
with Daniel
it's going to I think in the end of that
series get to a point where the furling
tries to steal some information there's
some data we know and don't trust him so
we catch him but he does end up escaping
with very advanced technology that we
don't understand I could see a scene
maybe where he's trying to steal data
and we maybe like use the anti-ori
technology on him thinking that that
will hold him and it does to a degree
but he somehow manages to adapt to that
technology and I could see the the final
scene whether so the gate just lights up
nothing happens but he just sort of like
turns into like that ghosty figure again
and disappears
stealing secret information and
important information about the SGC
now
a lot of people have said we can't do
this we can't have the feelings as a bad
guy
but we don't know enough about the
feelings to decide whether they would be
a potential villain or not we know about
the feelings that they try to create a
utopian society that then the goal
Awards stuck back down suicide planting
basically and everybody killed everybody
else we know that the feelings build
things like the weather changing
technology but we don't know really much
about them other than that we think we
might have seen them in one or two
episodes of Stargate and Stargate
Atlantis but we don't know for sure so
that gives us a whole opportunity to
create an entirely new villain basically
here based on a character we already
know a bit about and no they won't look
like evil Ewoks
I actually think in this series we
should see the feelings appear in lots
of different guises I would love to see
that they maybe don't have one specific
look that is dependent on where they are
and what they're doing maybe they're
shapeshifters I'd love to see that
now where have they been why have they
just returned
we are going to find out a version of
this story that the furling would tell
Daniel I think he would tell them that
they left the Galaxy after the Gold they
were pacifists the only way that they
could defeat the goal order was by
destroying them they didn't want to do
that so they were forced to leave
I'm going to actually say though that in
the next video I do that will be based
on series four we're going to see the
real reason why the feelings left and
even though the story that Daniel will
hear in the first season will be kind of
true it won't be the full truth
so guys get into the comments tell me
what you think about my little idea I
know I'm only sketching out an outline
here and there need to be a lot more in
there for a 10 or 12 episode series but
that's where you come in what sort of
episodes do you think would fit within
this story idea of this
introduction to Stargate command and
where could we go from there again in
the comments and tell me all of your
brilliant ideas
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you enjoy the content don't forget to
hit that join button and become a fully
fledged side tracker as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]